yeah but it's [ __ ] crazy like when
like i've seen you know say like
there are some family vloggers for
example that have been going on for like
you know
five ten years right now yeah and i'm
just like how are you guys like
okay mentally yeah because that would
drive me [ __ ] insane
yeah because like i i i get insane just
from
going to a bookstore and being like all
right i've got to find my next video
yeah right yeah let alone you do that
every moment of your life
being like all right what's something i
can like pick up and show on camera
to like show them that like we're living
a normal life yeah like
like also as well whenever i've hung out
with like youtubers it's normally always
like the newer ones or the smaller ones
who always want to like take a picture
and post everything because i think that
they haven't like experienced it yet
where they're like because
if you hang out with big youtubers
they're never like oh let's post this on
social media let's take a picture of the
post it's always like
oh we're not like i don't know there's
just like this kind of vibe that you get
around some people where you're like
all right cool this is going to be a
private thing nothing's going to be like
yeah
yeah weirdly weirdly it's like you
usually have to if if you're
interacting with a bigger youtuber you
usually have to be the one to be like
hey is it okay if i upload this
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah i would
ask i mean i if i'm with a bigger
youtuber i for some reason wanted to
post what i was doing
at that moment in time i would ask them
but i never do
i always like get like a [ __ ] sigh
when i'm like someone pulls out a camera
and they're gonna post it i'm like
alright yeah
all right we're gonna we're gonna do
that thing here we go i just wanted to
eat dinner but fine let's turn it into
something
like because to me it's like the only
like 100 percent escape i get it's just
like a nice [ __ ] meal
i don't know why i [ __ ] love you you
just like food i [ __ ] love food i
like food i mean who doesn't
to me like food is don't get me wrong
very tasty
very delicious and i can eat a lot i
like to think so yes
right but for me my favorite part about
food is like the social aspect of food
and like eating with someone and like
having it like be a
conversation and the food is like a
compliment to that yeah because it's a
shared experience that you can discuss
and if you don't know someone's like
well okay well maybe you could talk
about the food and then
it opens you up a little bit i don't
know i just really like
that aspect of it and i don't like that
being like ruined by
like by people trying to like moderate
right in front of your salary right i'm
just trying to enjoy my immaculate meal
my a5b my immaculate salad
and if i put and sometimes i'll post a
picture oh no sorry i'll take a picture
99 of the time i don't post it yeah just
for me i'm like i want to remember this
so i can know
that's something i've noticed recently i
i'd say especially in the last like two
or three years or so where
i've for some reason the more i do
social media and the more i used to post
now i post way less yeah i experience
more it's if that makes sense this is
like a lot of people ask
god why don't you post on instagram go
on post more on instagram
anything on instagram and i remember
i've tried so many times to get on my
insta
to like get more on my instagram and
that's just because i [ __ ]
hate having an experience right this is
the thing i hate the most having
some kind of experience whether it's a
nice meal or you're going somewhere new
and i like i feel pressured to document
it
yeah yeah like i gotta take a nice photo
of this for instagram like for one i
[ __ ] suck at taking photos oh yeah so
half the time i'm like trying to figure
out hey how do i make what i see
look good like like how do i do that
this is this is why i don't
work with like live-action stuff but i
also i just hate that
experience of just having to feel like i
need to document this i need to make
sure the world knows what i'm doing
and i feel like ever since i just
completely given up on my instagram yes
i i i've just given up at this point
everybody unfollow now you can unfollow
me i probably won't notice
but like as soon as i just gave up on it
then i just
you know i just it just felt like a
weight was off my shoulder right and i
feel like twitter for me is just way
more casual
i love twitter yeah like twitter i just
i don't have to try it's just like
i'd say any stupid shot that comes to my
mind dude i tweeted penis and it got 25
000 likes i'm like you guys will like
[ __ ] anything
but like with instagram yeah i'm kind of
the same like i i'm pretty i'm i'm not
going to sound
active on instagram like i'm most active
i'm probably the most active but
the thing is is that like i'd say the
past
10 to 15 photos i put up on instagram i
didn't take it was either aki took it or
somebody else like luke took a lot of
time like the recent ones because he's a
camera
i just never think when i'm at a place
i'm like i should take a picture like i
do
occasionally and there's pictures of my
instagram and places but most of the
time i never
think i should take a picture yeah i'm
just gonna enjoy it like i don't know
yeah
and that shouldn't be like a thing of
like wow look how amazing i am i
just you have nothing to prove right
it's like it's like i don't have to take
a nice photo of this trip i went to
to prove to you that oh i went on this
nice trip like like
you know that should just be something
that you should cherish not to say you
know don't post
your experiences on instagram like if
you're okay with it i did [ __ ] go for
it right yeah
but it's not a necessity especially if
you're
a content creator or a youtuber i think
it i think what we're saying
like more like w is about
other content creators or other
youtubers because as a content creator
you do commodify your life
and you need to find as i i learned that
i needed to find some parts of my life
that just weren't touched by youtube
yeah well i really have to like actively
make sure you're thinking about it i
also
think that when you're starting out it's
a lot easier to fall into the
the traps of self-employed because a lot
of the time youtubers are young
and you know i started when i was 19.
and i had no chill you were 19 when you
started yeah i'd known 19 when i started
how old were you when you started going
17 17. yeah i was 18 when i started and
uh yeah i find when you when the you get
that first initial growth
your thought is to pour everything into
it yeah
yeah i definitely did do that and i
definitely got burned out very quickly
because i was doing university as well
at the time yeah same so it was like i
was putting in a full 40 hour work week
on my youtube
and then i was putting probably not a
full 40 hour work week into my
university studies
oh no it was definitely like youtube
university for me right yeah and then my
social life was just
you know tumbleweed yeah uh yeah i mean
my and the sad thing is right is that
for every one of us that
you hear the success story you know
there's a lot of survivor bias with that
kind of stuff because
for every three youtubers like us that
did it
during a job or university we made it
through but
it's probably like 100 people who
[ __ ] sweated their ass off
full throughout university to get it to
work yeah and failed miserably yeah yeah
i didn't have anything to show for it
right like i took a gamble and it worked
off but it was a dumb gamble in reality
yeah but i was passionate about it but i
mean the more dumb gamble for you would
have been if you saw that little bit of
success and you're like
i'm gonna quit university which is
something you should never do